Our episodes deal with serious and often-distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis center. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings Please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners for all listeners. Married couple Debra and Sherwood Helmick worked hard to provide a comfortable life for their three young children. In mid 1985, the couple saved enough money to move out of the home they'd been sharing
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。已婚夫妇黛布拉和舍伍德·赫尔米克努力工作，为他们的三个年幼孩子提供舒适的生活。1985年中期，这对夫妇存够了钱，搬出了他们与亲戚合住的房子，搬进了属于自己的空间。
with relatives and into a space of their own. The Shiloh Mobile Home Park in South Carolina's Richland County provided modest yet pleasant accommodation. With just 13 trailers on the property, there was a relatively close-knit, hard-working community where residents looked out for one another. By June, the Helmix had been living at the trailer park for two months. Although their busy schedules didn't leave them much time for socializing with the other tenants, they were starting to settle in.
位于南卡罗来纳州里奇兰县的希洛移动房屋公园提供了朴素但舒适的住所。该物业只有13辆拖车，是一个相对紧密、勤劳的社区，居民们互相照顾。到六月，赫尔米克一家已经在拖车公园住了两个月。虽然他们忙碌的日程安排没有给他们留下太多时间与其他租户社交，但他们开始安顿下来。
On the afternoon of Friday, June 14, Debra prepared for her weight-racing shift at a local barbecue restaurant. Her husband Sherwood hadn't yet returned home from his construction job, so Debra had a little choice but to bring her three children along for the drive. Debra didn't have a car, but her neighbour Vicki was happy to help out. Vicki agreed to drop Debra at the restaurant and then keep an eye on her kids until Sherwood knocked off from work.
6月14日星期五下午，黛布拉为她在当地一家烧烤餐厅的轮班做准备。她的丈夫舍伍德还没有从建筑工地下班回家，所以黛布拉别无选择，只能带着她的三个孩子一起开车去。黛布拉没有车，但她的邻居薇琪很乐意帮忙。薇琪同意把黛布拉送到餐厅，然后帮她照看孩子，直到舍伍德下班。
Just as they were about to leave, Sherwood returned home. Six-year-old Becky still wanted to go for the drive, but nine-year-old Deborah May and three-year-old Woody decided to stay home. The youngsters said goodbye to their mother, then went to play outside, while their father cooled down indoors. Ricky Morgan lived in a neighbour neighboring trailer four doors down. At around 4pm, he heard a noise outside and looked out the window. A silver car that Ricky didn't recognise rapidly pulled into the trailer park. It stopped near the two homeic children who were playing out the front of their trailer.
就在他们准备离开时，舍伍德回到了家。六岁的贝基仍然想去兜风，但九岁的黛博拉·梅和三岁的伍迪决定留在家里。孩子们和母亲道别，然后去外面玩耍，而他们的父亲则在室内纳凉。里奇·摩根住在隔壁四扇门外的一辆拖车里。下午4点左右，他听到外面有噪音，便向窗外看去。一辆里奇不认识的银色汽车迅速驶入拖车公园。它停在正在拖车前玩耍的两个赫尔米克孩子附近。
A white male got out of the vehicle, leaving his motor running and the door open. He walked over and began speaking to the two children. In his hand appeared to be a white bag. Ricky didn't think much of it, assuming he was a friend of the family. But suddenly, the man grabbed Debra May around the waist and raced back towards his car. Debra May began kicking and screaming. The man threw her into his vehicle where Debra May continued to scream and started kicking the roof. By the time Ricky realized what was happening, it was too late.
一名白人男子从车里走出来，没熄火，车门也没关。他走过去开始和两个孩子说话。他手里似乎拿着一个白色的袋子。里奇没多想，以为他是这家的朋友。但突然，那名男子抓住黛博拉·梅的腰，冲回他的车里。黛博拉·梅开始踢打尖叫。那名男子把她扔进车里，黛博拉·梅继续尖叫并开始踢车顶。当里奇意识到发生了什么事时，已经太晚了。
He raced outside, but the car sped past him and out of the trailer park. Three-year-old Woody desperately scrambled underneath a nearby bush, shaking with fear. When asked what happened, a terrified Woody later explained. The bad man said he was coming back to get me. Sherwood Helmi could be in just 20 feet away, getting changed in his bedroom, where the buzzing of his air conditioner unit drowned out the sound of his daughter's screams. But a friend who had given him a lift home from work was sitting in the front room of the Helmick's trailer and overheard the commotion. He told Sherwood what was going on and that the two quickly raced outside, just quick enough to catch a glimpse of the silver car as it disappeared down Old Percival Road, a long rural stretch running through
他冲到外面，但车子从他身边疾驰而过，驶出了拖车公园。三岁的伍迪绝望地爬进附近的一丛灌木下，吓得发抖。当被问及发生了什么事时，惊恐的伍迪后来解释说：“坏人说他会回来抓我。”舍伍德·赫尔米克当时就在20英尺外，正在卧室里换衣服，空调机的嗡嗡声淹没了他女儿的尖叫声。但一位开车送他回家的朋友正坐在赫尔米克家拖车的前厅，听到了骚动。他告诉舍伍德发生了什么事，两人迅速冲到外面，刚好瞥见银色汽车消失在老珀西瓦尔路上，这是一条穿过
the heart of Richland County. They jumped in Sherwood's France car and gave chase, but the vehicle was long gone. Officers were alerted and a search for the nine-year-old kicked off immediately. Trailer Park resident Ricky Morgan had gotten a decent look at the kidnapper, describing him as aged in his early to mid-30s, 5'9 and weighing roughly 200 pounds. He had a brown, receding hairline, short brown beard and was wearing shorts with a light coloured sleeveless top. The car itself had a red stripes down the cert and was possibly a 1982 or 1983 model Chevrolet Monte Carlo, or Pontiac Grand Prix. Tire tracks at the trailer park were consistent with it being a general motor's model vehicle.
里奇兰县中心的一条漫长的乡村道路。他们跳上舍伍德的车进行追赶，但那辆车早已不见踪影。警方接到警报，立即对这名九岁的女孩展开搜寻。拖车公园居民里奇·摩根看清了绑架者的样子，描述他年龄在30岁出头到30岁中期，身高5英尺9英寸，体重约200磅。他有棕色的后移发际线，留着短棕色胡须，穿着短裤和浅色无袖上衣。车子本身侧面有红色条纹，可能是1982年或1983年的雪佛兰蒙特卡洛或庞蒂亚克大奖赛车型。拖车公园的轮胎痕迹与通用汽车的车型一致。
Ricky had caught a glimpse of the South Carolina license plate just long enough to see that it started with the letter D. The Helmix were beside themselves. They had no known enemies and couldn't think of anyone who would want to harm their daughter. Debra May was an incredibly smart young girl who was obedient, well behaved and a little shy, not the type to speak to strangers. Although the Helmix mostly kept to themselves, neighbors described them as a likable family. No one had noticed any other suspicious behavior around the property. The only plausible explanation seemed to be that Debra May had been the target of an opportunistic predator.
里奇瞥见了南卡罗来纳州的车牌，时间刚好够看到它以字母D开头。赫尔米克夫妇心急如焚。他们没有已知的敌人，也想不出有谁会想伤害他们的女儿。黛博拉·梅是一个非常聪明的年轻女孩，听话、懂事，还有点害羞，不是那种会和陌生人说话的孩子。虽然赫尔米克一家大多独来独往，但邻居们形容他们是一个讨人喜欢的家庭。没有人注意到该物业周围有任何其他可疑行为。唯一合理的解释似乎是黛博拉·梅成为了一个机会主义掠夺者的目标。
For investigators, there were a couple of details that caused particular concern. Debra May Helmick's abduction had occurred on the two-week anniversary of Shari Smith's kidnapping, right down to the hour. The two girls lived roughly 24 miles apart. Both had been brazenly taken from the front of their own homes while their parents stood nearby oblivious to what was happening. Although there was an eight-year-age difference between Shari and Debra May, they shared similar physical characteristics, both were blonde with blue eyes.
对于调查人员来说，有几个细节引起了特别的关注。黛博拉·梅·赫尔米克的绑架案发生在沙里·史密斯被绑架两周纪念日，精确到小时。这两个女孩住的地方相距约24英里。两人都是在父母站在附近却对发生的事情一无所知的情况下，被公然从自家门前带走的。虽然沙里和黛博拉·梅之间有八岁的年龄差，但她们有着相似的身体特征，都是金发蓝眼。
There were immediate concerns that Debra May could have fallen victim to the same fate as Shari. At the time of her kidnapping, nine days had passed since Shari Smith's body had been discovered, and despite their tireless efforts, investigators were no closer to identifying her killer. Witness Ricky Morgan was shown the suspect sketch of Sherry's abductor and to notice similarities to the man who had taken Debra May. Although the man Ricky witnessed was younger in Stokia, with darker hair and a beard.
人们立即担心黛博拉·梅可能遭遇了与沙里相同的命运。在她被绑架时，沙里·史密斯的尸体被发现已经过去了九天，尽管他们付出了不懈的努力，但调查人员在确定凶手身份方面没有任何进展。目击者里奇·摩根被展示了沙里绑架者的嫌疑人素描，并注意到与带走黛博拉·梅的男子有相似之处。虽然里奇目击的男子更年轻、更结实，留着深色头发和胡须。
He also drove a completely different vehicle. It was believed that Sherry had been forced into her attack as car at gunpoint, yet Debra May had been physically grabbed. If the two attacks weren't linked, this prompted another terrifying possibility. What if Sherry's killer had inspired a copycat? If the same perpetrator was responsible for both the doctions, police held grave concerns for Debra Maze welfare.
他还开着一辆完全不同的车。据信沙里是在枪口下被迫进入袭击者的车，而黛博拉·梅则是被强行抓走的。如果这两起袭击没有关联，这引发了另一种可怕的可能性。如果沙里的凶手启发了一个模仿者呢？如果同一个肇事者对这两起绑架案负责，警方对黛博拉·梅的安危深感担忧。
They wasted no time in launching a full-scale investigation, with officers from surrounding counties called into assist, while helicopters surveilled overhead. If the Smith case had taught them anything, it was that the perpetrator thrived on power and attention. Investigators therefore anticipated that if the same person was responsible for both crimes, it was a matter of time before he contacted Debra Maise family. But there was one issue. The Helmix didn't have a phone. If the 9-year-old had been targeted at random, the perpetrator likely didn't know this.
他们毫不耽搁地展开了全面调查，周边县的警官被召集来协助，直升机在头顶监视。如果说史密斯案教会了他们什么，那就是肇事者靠权力和关注为生。因此，调查人员预计，如果同一个人对这两起罪行负责，他迟早会联系黛博拉·梅的家人。但有一个问题。赫尔米克一家没有电话。如果这个9岁的孩子是随机被选中的，肇事者可能不知道这一点。
Instead, investigators monitored the phone in the manager's office of the trailer park. But the days ticked by and the kidnapper remained silent. When the Smith family found out about Debra M's abduction, the first thing they did was pray for the Helmix. They told reporters, we knew when we lost Shari that no one could give us as much comfort as God. That was able to strengthen us and we want to pass that along. Unlike the Smith family, the Helmicks refrained from making any public appeals.
相反，调查人员监控了拖车公园经理办公室的电话。但日子一天天过去，绑架者保持沉默。当史密斯一家得知黛博拉·梅被绑架的消息时，他们做的第一件事就是为赫尔米克一家祈祷。他们告诉记者：“我们失去沙里时就知道，没有人能像上帝那样给我们这么多安慰。上帝能够坚强我们，我们想把这一点传递下去。”与史密斯一家不同，赫尔米克一家没有进行任何公开呼吁。
They were too traumatized. Sherwood was unable to cope with the fact that his daughter had been taken while he was mere meters away, and he wept uncontrollably. His wife Debra sunk into a deep depression, blacking out from stress and requiring medical care. They clung desperately onto the hope that Debra May would be found alive, but the very real possibility that that may not be the case left them crippled with the stress. Sure would refuse to let his other two children out of his sight.
他们受到了太大的创伤。舍伍德无法接受他的女儿在他仅几米远的地方被带走的事实，他无法控制地哭泣。他的妻子黛布拉陷入了深深的抑郁，因压力而昏厥，需要医疗护理。他们绝望地紧紧抓住黛博拉·梅能活着被找到的希望，但这种可能性非常渺茫，这让他们因压力而瘫痪。舍伍德拒绝让他的另外两个孩子离开他的视线。
When he finally summoned the strength to speak to a reporter for the Columbia record, he said, You've got a wacko out there, and you never know what he might do. Up until this point, the composite sketch of Sherry Smith's abductor had been withheld from the public. Desperate for Leeds, the decision was made to release it for the first time. It prompted an overwhelming response. With the abduction of a second young girl from neighboring counties, the already fearful
当他终于鼓起勇气对《哥伦比亚记录报》的一名记者说话时，他说：“外面有个疯子，你永远不知道他会做什么。”在此之前，沙里·史密斯绑架者的合成素描一直对公众保密。由于急需线索，当局决定首次发布它。这引起了巨大的反响。随着第二个年轻女孩在邻近县被绑架，本已恐惧的
community became increasingly paranoid. Everyone was viewed with suspicion. Police tiplines rang off the hook with locals wanting to report everything from psychic visions to their own personal theories. Officers who were already working around the clock to try and solve Sherry Smith's murder were thrown into a spin with the introduction of a second possibly linked case. Hours of crucial investigative time went into checking license plate numbers, as tipsters reported every suspicious bearded man driving a car similar to the one's witness during
社区变得越来越偏执。每个人都被视为可疑。警方的举报电话响个不停，当地人想报告从通灵幻象到他们个人理论的一切。那些已经在全天候工作试图解决沙里·史密斯谋杀案的警官们，随着第二起可能有关联的案件的出现，陷入了混乱。数小时的关键调查时间花在了核对车牌号码上，因为举报人报告了每一个在绑架期间驾驶与目击车辆相似的留胡子男子。
the abductions. Complicating matters further was the fact that both kidnappings and the dumping of Shari's body had taken place in different jurisdictions, leading to issues when it came to communication and coordination between the different law enforcement agencies. One official appeared on the news, he stressed evident as he told reporters, We are on an 18 hour work schedule now. We just can't take really much more.
更复杂的是，两起绑架案和沙里尸体的抛弃地点发生在不同的司法管辖区，导致不同执法机构之间的沟通和协调出现问题。一名官员出现在新闻中，他压力重重地告诉记者：“我们现在实行18小时工作制。我们真的承受不了更多了。”
With the rumor mill swinging into overdrive and wreaking havoc on both investigators and the public, Lexington County Sheriff James Matt's took a media vow of silence, refusing to speak about either case until substantial progress was made. Although investigators were treading with caution in case both abductions were linked, they still had no evidence to confirm this. Debra May Helmix case was being treated as a missing person investigation, and hopes continued to be held that she'd be found alive. Just like they had with the Smith case, the community rallied behind the
随着谣言四起，对调查人员和公众造成了严重破坏，列克星敦县警长詹姆斯·梅茨采取了媒体沉默誓言，拒绝谈论任何案件，直到取得实质性进展。尽管调查人员在处理两起绑架案是否有关联时非常谨慎，但他们仍然没有任何证据证实这一点。黛博拉·梅·赫尔米克的案件被当作失踪人口调查处理，人们继续抱有她能活着被找到的希望。就像在史密斯案中一样，社区团结在
Helmix with an outpouring of support in the form of food and financial donations. It was impossible for other parents not to put themselves in the Helmix shoes, with the one woman remarking, every time one of my children walks out the door, I pray to God that they'll come back safely. Sherwood Helmick told reporters he was optimistic that investigators would solve his daughter's case within a couple of days. But by the time Sherry's killer made contact with Dawn Smith on Saturday, June 22, Debra May had been missing for eight days. As soon as the caller asked Dawn Smith if she had, quote, heard about Debra May Hamrick, investigators listening in hung on to his every word. Dawn was aware of the young girl's kidnapping, but she responded, no.
赫尔米克一家身后，以食物和经济捐赠的形式提供了大量的支持。其他父母不可能不设身处地为赫尔米克一家着想，一位妇女评论道：“每次我的孩子走出家门，我都祈祷上帝保佑他们能平安回来。”舍伍德·赫尔米克告诉记者，他乐观地认为调查人员会在几天内破获他女儿的案件。但当沙里的凶手在6月22日星期六联系道恩·史密斯时，黛博拉·梅已经失踪了八天。当打电话的人问道恩·史密斯是否“听说过黛博拉·梅·赫尔米克”时，监听的调查人员紧紧抓住他的每一个字。道恩知道这个年轻女孩被绑架的事，但她回答说：“没有。”
Realising he had mispronounced Debra May's surname, the caller corrected himself and said, Helmic. This time, Dawn responded that, yes, she did know about Debra May. Okay, now listen carefully, said her sister's killer. Go one north, well one west, turn left at Peach Festival Road or Bill's Grill, go three and a half miles through Gilbert, turn right, last dirt road before you come to stop sign at to not road. Go through chain and no trespassing sign. Go 50 yards and to the left go 10 yards. Debra May is waiting.
意识到自己读错了黛博拉·梅的姓氏，打电话的人纠正自己说：“赫尔米克。”这一次，道恩回答说，是的，她确实知道黛博拉·梅。“好了，现在仔细听，”她姐姐的凶手说，“向北走一英里，向西走一英里，在桃子节路或比尔烧烤店左转，穿过吉尔伯特走三英里半，右转，在到达禁止通行标志前的最后一条土路。穿过链条和禁止进入标志。走50码，然后向左走10码。黛博拉·梅在那里等着。”
God forgive us all. The location the caller had described was in Lexington County, roughly 14 miles west of the Smithsome, and to 30 miles from the Helmix. The manner in which he'd given directions was so similar to the way he described the location of Sherry's body, that officers descending on the scene had a little doubt as to what they would find there. Following the instructions took them to a remote location in the back roads outside the small town of Gilbert, where they located the no trespassing sign as described. It led Denny Hill that backed on to a wooded area. At the bottom of the hill lay the body of Debra Maesbody was severely decomposed to the point that her exact cause of death couldn't be ascertained.
上帝宽恕我们所有人。打电话的人描述的地点在列克星敦县，距离史密斯家约14英里，距离赫尔米克家30英里。他提供方向的方式与他描述沙里尸体位置的方式非常相似，以至于赶往现场的警官对他们会在那里发现什么几乎没有怀疑。按照指示，他们来到了吉尔伯特小镇外偏僻的乡村道路上，在那里他们找到了描述中的禁止进入标志。它通向一个背靠树林的荒凉山坡。在山坡底部躺着黛博拉·梅的尸体，尸体严重腐烂，以至于无法确定她的确切死因。
However, the residue of adhesive material in her hair indicated that she too had likely been suffocated. The nine-year-old was still dressed in the same clothing she'd been wearing at the time of her abduction, pinstriped shorts and 11-to-coloured t-shirt. The level of decomposition meant it couldn't be determined whether she'd been sexually assaulted, but evidence found on her body indicated there was a sexual motivation to the crime. Debra May was still wearing the same pair of cotton underwear she'd been dressed in on
然而，她头发中残留的粘合剂表明，她也可能被窒息而死。这个九岁的孩子仍然穿着她被绑架时穿的衣服，细条纹短裤和一件浅色T恤。腐烂程度意味着无法确定她是否受到性侵犯，但从她尸体上发现的证据表明，这起犯罪有性动机。黛博拉·梅仍然穿着她被绑架那天穿的那条棉质内裤。
the day of her kidnapping. But over the top was a pair of adult women's silk bikini briefs. When criminal profiler John Douglas heard this detail, it gave him further insight into what kind of perpetrator they were dealing with. As explained in his book, when a killer calls, Douglas suspected that the killer wouldn't feel particularly good about taking a child victim. With Shari Smith, he could convince himself that the two had some kind of reasonable relationship. Without this delusion, he would likely feel somewhat ashamed of his actions.
但在外面套着一条成年女性的丝绸比基尼内裤。当犯罪侧写师约翰·道格拉斯听到这个细节时，这让他进一步了解了他们正在处理的是什么样的肇事者。正如他在书《当杀手来电时》中所解释的那样，道格拉斯怀疑凶手在带走儿童受害者时不会感觉特别好。对于沙里·史密斯，他可以说服自己，两人之间有某种合理的关系。没有这种错觉，他可能会对自己行为感到有些羞耻。
Douglas believed it was likely that the adult underwear belonged to another of the killer's victims. By putting them on Debra May, it was possible he was trying to diminish his guilt about attacking a child. The call placed to Dawn Smith was traced to a payphone outside a Kentucky Fried Chicken fast food restaurant in the South Carolina town of Sumter, roughly 72 miles from where Debra May's body was found. As was the case with all his previous calls, the killer had left behind no discernible
道格拉斯认为，那条成人内裤很可能属于凶手的另一名受害者。通过把它穿在黛博拉·梅身上，他可能是在试图减轻自己攻击儿童的罪恶感。打给道恩·史密斯的电话被追踪到南卡罗来纳州萨姆特镇一家肯德基快餐店外的公用电话，距离发现黛博拉·梅尸体的地方约72英里。和他之前所有的电话一样，凶手没有留下任何可辨认的
clues. But with the addition of a second body and a second crime scene, investigators were able to piece together a few more details about the perpetrator. The remote location where Debra May's body was found added further weight to the belief that the killer lived locally. Like the Masonic lodge where Sherry's body was dumped, this wasn't the kind of location one would just stumble upon by accident. Furthermore, the fact that he'd scattered his crimes among three different counties supported the theory that he had knowledge of forensic proceedings. Investigators believed he'd intentionally spread his offenses between jurisdictions, knowing it would hinder the investigation. By this point, 22 days had passed since Sherry Smith had been abducted.
线索。但随着第二具尸体和第二个犯罪现场的出现，调查人员能够拼凑出关于肇事者的更多细节。发现黛博拉·梅尸体的偏僻地点进一步加重了凶手是当地人的看法。就像抛弃沙里尸体的共济会会所一样，这不是那种人们会偶然发现的地方。此外，他将罪行分散在三个不同县的事实支持了他了解法医程序的理论。调查人员认为，他故意将罪行分散在不同司法管辖区，知道这会阻碍调查。到此时，沙里·史密斯被绑架已经过去了22天。
In that time, the perpetrator had successfully pulled off a second abduction and two murders. He'd made multiple calls to Sherry Smith's family and one to news reporter Charlie Keys. Yet, despite unrelenting efforts made by multiple law enforcement agencies, including the FBI, no prime suspects had emerged. On his latest call to Dawn Smith, the killer didn't disguise his voice. This indicated two possibilities. Either he was getting sloppy, or he was getting cocky. The Helmix were saved from having to view their daughter's body by identifying her based on her clothing instead. As soon as Deborah Helmix saw the pink hair clip she'd placed
在那段时间里，肇事者成功实施了第二次绑架和两起谋杀。他多次给沙里·史密斯的家人打电话，并给新闻记者查理·基斯打了一个。然而，尽管多个执法机构（包括联邦调查局）做出了不懈努力，但没有出现主要嫌疑人。在他最近打给道恩·史密斯的电话中，凶手没有伪装他的声音。这表明有两种可能。要么他变得粗心大意，要么他变得自大。赫尔米克一家通过衣服辨认出了女儿，从而免于查看女儿的尸体。当黛博拉·赫尔米克看到她那天早上出门前放在
in her daughter's hair before leaving for work on the day of the abduction, her worst nightmare was confirmed. As the grieving parents came to terms with their loss, a press conference was held for police to break the news to the public. Shara for James Metz reluctantly confirmed what everyone had been fearing since Debra May was taken. A serial killer was on the loose. Metz urged parents to remain vigilant, saying, I don't want to frighten anybody, but as your sheriff, it is my duty to tell you that you should exercise extra caution during these trying times.
女儿头发上的粉色发夹时，她最可怕的噩梦得到了证实。当悲痛的父母接受他们的损失时，警方举行了新闻发布会，向公众发布了消息。詹姆斯·梅茨警长不情愿地证实了自黛博拉·梅被带走以来每个人都在担心的事。一个连环杀手逍遥法外。梅茨敦促父母保持警惕，他说：“我不想吓唬任何人，但作为你们的警长，我有责任告诉你们，在这些艰难时期，你们应该格外小心。”
The suspect sketch was revised to reflect the sightings from both kidnappings and was published in all the local papers. It showed a white, heavy-set male aged between 28 and 35, with long-ish hair and a dark beard. Although if Profileur John Douglas' assumptions were anything to go by, the perpetrator's physical appearance would likely have changed since his crimes breed kicked off. He might be losing or gaining weight, looking un-camped, and could be drinking heavily. If members of the public were paranoid before, they were now well and truly petrified. Panicked parents vied for a spot in a community program about child safety, while concerned
嫌疑人素描经过修改，反映了两次绑架案的目击情况，并发表在所有当地报纸上。它显示了一名白人、体格健壮的男性，年龄在28到35岁之间，留着长发和深色胡须。虽然如果侧写师约翰·道格拉斯的假设有任何参考价值的话，肇事者的外貌自他犯罪开始以来可能已经发生了变化。他可能正在减肥或增重，看起来不修边幅，并且可能酗酒。如果公众之前是偏执的，那么他们现在确实是彻底被吓坏了。恐慌的父母争抢社区儿童安全项目的名额，而忧心忡忡的
citizens sought out self-defense classes, and continued to report even the most remotely suspicious activity. People called the police to voice concerns that their families could be targeted next. Tip line switchboards were completely overwhelmed with unsubstantiated rumors, with police becoming so inundated that they threatened to prosecute anyone
市民寻求自卫课程，并继续报告即使是最微不足道的可疑活动。人们打电话给警察，表达对家人可能成为下一个目标的担忧。举报电话总机被毫无根据的谣言完全淹没，警察变得如此不堪重负，以至于他们威胁要起诉任何
who deliberately hindered the investigation. As journalist Margaret O'Shea rode in the state newspaper. Other crimes have shocked the public conscience, and other murders have provoked community outrage. But none have so completely gripped the Middellands in intense pervasive fear as have the abductions and deaths of Shari Smith and Debra May Helmick. The terror has circumscribed to the lives and thoughts of thousands, consumed with the stark and dreadful knowledge that a bold killer or killers were at large. No driveway, no front yard, no pool or pond,
故意阻碍调查的人。正如记者玛格丽特·奥谢在州报纸上所写的那样：“其他罪行震惊了公众良知，其他谋杀案激起了社区愤怒。但没有哪起案件像沙里·史密斯和黛博拉·梅·赫尔米克的绑架和死亡那样，让米德兰地区陷入如此彻底、强烈且普遍的恐惧之中。恐怖已经限制了成千上万人的生活和思想，他们被一个大胆的杀手或杀手逍遥法外的严酷而可怕的事实所吞噬。没有车道，没有前院，没有游泳池或池塘，
no place where children play could be assumed to be safe anymore. Despite the killer claiming a second victim and the ongoing concerns that Dawn Smith could be targeted next, the Smith family agreed to go ahead with the staged memorial service for Shry's birthday as planned. On Tuesday, June 25, undercover officers strategically placed themselves around the cemetery, while covert security guards lay in wait in case anyone tried to cause any harm. When the service ended, Dawn took one of Sherry's cherished stuffed koalas and placed it on her grave.
没有孩子玩耍的地方可以再被认为是安全的了。”尽管凶手声称有了第二个受害者，并且人们持续担心道恩·史密斯可能成为下一个目标，但史密斯一家同意按计划为沙里的生日举行纪念仪式。6月25日星期二，便衣警察战略性地部署在墓地周围，而秘密保安人员则在暗处守候，以防有人试图造成任何伤害。仪式结束时，道恩拿走了沙里珍爱的毛绒考拉之一，并把它放在了她的坟墓上。
Various members of the press were there to report on the event in the hopes the media attention would re-engage the killer to make further contact. Speaking afterwards to the Columbia record, Bob Smith said the only way they coped was through their belief in God. Hilda ratted, it's even harder today knowing that this is the day you gave birth and she's not here with you. Knowing she's not ever going to be here with you again. The following day was Debra Ma's funeral.
各路媒体都在现场报道这一事件，希望媒体的关注能促使凶手再次联系。事后对《哥伦比亚记录报》发表讲话时，鲍勃·史密斯说，他们应对的唯一方式是通过对上帝的信仰。希尔达哭诉道：“今天更难受，因为知道这是你生下她的日子，而她却不在这里。知道她再也不会在这里陪你了。”第二天是黛博拉·梅的葬礼。
Over 300 people gathered to mourn the loss of the smart young girl who dreamed of becoming a teacher or school principal. The presiding minister told those in attendance. This is a very difficult time for all of us. We are afraid, angry and confused. We are all sad and broken. We are afraid for our children. We don't feel safe in our front yards.
300多人聚集在一起，哀悼这位梦想成为教师或小学校长的聪明年轻女孩的离世。主持牧师告诉在场的人：“这对我们所有人来说都是一个非常困难的时刻。我们感到害怕、愤怒和困惑。我们都感到悲伤和破碎。我们为我们的孩子感到害怕。我们在前院感到不安全。”
We distrust every stranger. We ask, when will it end? Convinced that the killer could be among the crowd, playing clothes officers were positioned around the cemetery while a police helicopter circled overhead. Meanwhile, Sherry's gravesite was surveilled around the clock, and the licence played of every vehicle that passed by was taken down. But the trap didn't appear to be working. No one made any attempt to take the stuffed koala, nor had the killer made a peep. All that didn't matter.
“我们不信任每一个陌生人。我们问，什么时候才会结束？”确信凶手可能就在人群中，便衣警察被部署在墓地周围，而一架警用直升机在头顶盘旋。与此同时，沙里的墓地被全天候监视，每一辆经过的车辆的车牌都被记录下来。但陷阱似乎没有奏效。没有人试图拿走毛绒考拉，凶手也没有发出任何声音。所有这些都不重要了。
On the same day that Debra May Helmick was late to rest, specialists were finally able to run Sherry Smith's last Willan Testament through an electronic detection apparatus, known as an ESDA machine. With the use of graphite, an ESDA can pick up images that aren't visible to the naked eye, such as indentations left on paper. The ESDA revealed several latent impressions on Sherry's last will and testament. On the same pad she'd used to write her letter, someone had written what appeared to be a grocery list.
在黛博拉·梅·赫尔米克入土为安的同一天，专家们终于能够通过一种称为ESDA机器的电子检测设备运行沙里·史密斯的最后遗嘱。利用石墨，ESDA可以拾取肉眼看不见的图像，例如纸上留下的压痕。ESDA在沙里的最后遗嘱上揭示了几个潜在的印记。在她用来写信的同一张纸垫上，有人写下了看起来像是购物清单的东西。
But that wasn't all. There was a string of numbers. Looking closely, investigators realized what they were looking at. A phone number. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Habits are part of who we are and shape us into who we're becoming. Some are good and some are not so good. Breaking those bad habits can radically change your life for the better, and that's why we're glad to have FUME sponsored this episode.
但这还不是全部。有一串数字。仔细观察，调查人员意识到他们看到的是什么。一个电话号码。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。习惯是我们的一部分，塑造了我们正在成为的人。有些是好的，有些则不那么好。改掉那些坏习惯可以从根本上改变你的生活，这就是为什么我们很高兴有FUME赞助这一集。
FUME is an innovative, award-nominated device that helps you break bad habits. Instead of electronics, fume is completely natural. Instead of vapor, fume uses flavoured air. And instead of harmful chemicals, fume uses all natural, delicious flavours. Your fume comes with an adjustable air flow dial and is designed with movable parts and magnets for fidgeting, giving your fingers a lot to do, which is helpful for de-stressing and anxiety while breaking your habit. If you're using fume for the first time, you'll be pleasantly surprised by how flavourful
FUME是一款创新的、获得提名的设备，可以帮助你改掉坏习惯。FUME不是电子产品，而是完全天然的。FUME不使用蒸汽，而是使用调味空气。FUME不使用有害化学物质，而是使用全天然、美味的口味。你的FUME配有一个可调节的气流旋钮，并设计有可移动的部件和磁铁供你摆弄，让你的手指有事可做，这对于在改掉习惯的同时缓解压力和焦虑很有帮助。如果你是第一次使用FUME，你会对它有多么美味
and fresh it is. It's also incredibly well designed with real wood and light weight, so it not only tastes good, but looks good too. Holding yourself hostage with your bad habits is the worst crime you could commit. It's time to break bad habits, and our sponsor Fume can help. Fume has served over 100,000 customers and has thousands of success stories, and there's no reason that can't be you. Join Fume in accelerating humanity's breakup from destructive habits by picking up the journey pack today. Head to TriFume.com and use code CaseFile to save 10% off when you get the journey pack
和清新感到惊喜。它设计得也非常出色，采用实木材质，重量轻，所以它不仅味道好，看起来也很好。用坏习惯绑架自己是你可能犯下的最严重的罪行。是时候改掉坏习惯了，我们的赞助商FUME可以提供帮助。FUME已经服务了超过10万名客户，拥有数千个成功案例，没有理由你不能成为其中之一。加入FUME，通过今天购买旅行套装，加速人类摆脱破坏性习惯的进程。前往TryFume.com并使用代码CaseFile，在今天购买旅行套装时节省10%
today. That's try FUM.com and use Code CaseFile to save an additional 10% off your order today. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. The discovery of a latent phone number on Sherry Smith's final letter was a major breakthrough, but there was just one problem. Only nine digits of the 10 digit phone number were visible. Investigators could make out the first three digits, 205. This was the interstate area
即TryFUM.com并使用代码CaseFile，今天购买可额外节省10%。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。在沙里·史密斯的最后一封信上发现一个潜在的电话号码是一个重大突破，但只有一个问题。10位电话号码中只有9位可见。调查人员可以辨认出前三位数字，205。这是阿拉巴马州的州际区号。
code for Alabama. The next three digits were 837, which was the local exchange for Huntsville, and Alabama City roughly 380 miles west of Lexington. But of the last four digits, only three were visible. This was only a minor setback. Investigators realized the missing number could only be one of 10 options. They tried every possible combination and cross-checked each one against phone records to identify if any of the Huntsville numbers had communications around the Lexington County area.
接下来的三位数字是837，这是亨茨维尔的本地交换台，阿拉巴马州的一个城市，距离列克星敦以西约380英里。但在最后四位数字中，只有三位可见。这只是一个小挫折。调查人员意识到缺失的数字只有10种选择。他们尝试了每一种可能的组合，并将每一种组合与电话记录进行交叉核对，以确定亨茨维尔的任何号码是否在列克星敦县地区有过通信。
One of them had. One investigator dialed the number. A friendly sounding man answered. He sounded like he was in his 20s or 30s, but his voice didn't match the killer. He said his name was Joe Shepard, and that he was stationed at an army base, which he hadn't left in recent weeks. But when asked if he knew anyone in South Carolina, Joe said yes. His parents lived in Saluda County. 50-year-old Ella Shepard was an electrician.
其中一个有过。一名调查人员拨打了这个号码。一个声音友好的男人接听了。他听起来像是在20多岁或30多岁，但他的声音与凶手不符。他说他的名字叫乔·谢泼德，他驻扎在一个陆军基地，最近几周没有离开过。但当被问及是否认识南卡罗来纳州的任何人时，乔说是的。他的父母住在萨卢达县。50岁的埃利斯·谢泼德是一名电工。
He and his wife Sharon lived near Lake Murray less than 10 miles from the home of Shari Smith and just two miles from the location where Debra May Helmix body was found. Investigators immediately descended on their home, but as soon as they met the couple, it was blatantly obvious that Ellis didn't fit the profile of Shari and Debra May's killer. For starters, he was older and didn't match the suspect description. Secondly, he had a squeaky clean criminal record with no prior run-ins with the law.
他和妻子莎伦住在默里湖附近，距离沙里·史密斯的家不到10英里，距离发现黛博拉·梅·赫尔米克尸体的地方仅两英里。调查人员立即赶到他们家，但当他们见到这对夫妇时，很明显埃利斯不符合沙里和黛博拉·梅凶手的侧写。首先，他年纪较大，不符合嫌疑人描述。其次，他有清白的犯罪记录，之前没有与法律发生过冲突。
Thirdly, he and Sharon were happily married, going against the belief that the perpetrator would be a loner with the history of failed relationships. Although the shepherds were caught off guard by the police presence, nothing in Ellis's demeanor indicated that he was nervous. When asked if they knew about the recent abductions and murders happening in the area, the couple said yes, they were aware of them, but they'd been out of town at the time that each incident had occurred, and they didn't know all of the details.
第三，他和莎伦婚姻幸福，这与肇事者是一个有失败关系史的孤独者的看法相悖。虽然谢泼德夫妇被警察的出现弄得措手不及，但埃利斯的举止中没有任何迹象表明他很紧张。当被问及他们是否知道该地区最近发生的绑架和谋杀案时，这对夫妇说是的，他们知道，但每起事件发生时他们都不在城里，而且他们不知道所有的细节。
They could think of no reason why their son's phone number could have appeared on the final letter written by one of the victims. The investigators described the behavioral profile of the killer to the shepherds, and implored them to think if there was anyone they knew who fit that description. The two exchanged and knowing glance. Over the past month, Sharon and Ellis had been away traveling. One of Ellis' electrical assistance had been house-sitting for them during that time. The couple had left him a list of phone numbers on yellow legal paper that he could call
他们想不出为什么他们儿子的电话号码会出现在其中一名受害者写的最后一封信上。调查人员向谢泼德夫妇描述了凶手的行为侧写，并恳求他们想一想是否认识符合该描述的人。两人交换了一个心照不宣的眼神。过去一个月，莎伦和埃利斯一直在外旅行。埃利斯的一名电气助手在那段时间一直为他们看家。这对夫妇在黄色法律用纸上给他留下了一份电话号码清单，以便他在紧急情况下拨打。
in case of an emergency. One of those numbers was for their son, Joe. As the shepherds considered the criminal profile, they realized just how many of those factors matched their house sitter. But it wasn't until they were played a recording of the killer's voice that they knew for sure. 30 Son of a Bitch, Ella said. That's Larry Jean Bell.
其中一个号码是他们儿子乔的。当谢泼德夫妇考虑犯罪侧写时，他们意识到有多少因素与他们的看家助手相符。但直到他们听到凶手声音的录音，他们才确定无疑。“那个狗娘养的，”埃利斯说，“那是拉里·吉恩·贝尔。”
36-year-old Larry Jean Bell was a South Carolina local. Just like the profile anticipated, it once been married with a child, but the relationship ended in divorce, after which Bell's ex-wife and son relocated into state. Bell had previously served in the Marines, but was discharged within a year after he accidentally shot himself in the knee while cleaning his gun. Since then, he'd had a range of jobs, including prison guard, airline reservations clerk, and electronic contractor. A search of Bell's background revealed that 10 years prior, he had approached a young woman at Knife Point and tried to force her into his car. A passer by heard the woman screams
36岁的拉里·吉恩·贝尔是南卡罗来纳州本地人。正如侧写所预料的那样，他曾经结过婚并有一个孩子，但这段关系以离婚告终，之后贝尔的前妻和儿子搬到了州外。贝尔曾在美国海军陆战队服役，但在清理枪支时意外射中自己的膝盖后，不到一年就被开除了。从那以后，他做过各种工作，包括监狱看守、航空公司预订员和电子承包商。对贝尔背景的搜索显示，10年前，他曾持刀接近一名年轻女子，并试图强迫她进入他的车。一名路人听到了女子的尖叫声
and called the police, who arrested Belle as he tried to flee. Belle pleaded guilty to assault and battery and was sentenced to five years in prison, a sentence that was ultimately suspended in favor of him paying a $1,000 fine. Eight months after this failed attack, Belle was in Colombia when he saw a woman slip and fall. In the process of helping her to her fate, Bell flashed a gun and tried to force the woman into his car.
并报了警，警察在贝尔试图逃跑时逮捕了他。贝尔承认犯有袭击和殴打罪，被判处五年监禁，该判决最终被缓刑，条件是他支付1000美元罚款。这次失败的袭击八个月后，贝尔在哥伦比亚看到一名女子滑倒。在帮助她脱困的过程中，贝尔亮出一把枪，试图强迫该女子进入他的车。
Again, she fought back and Bell was arrested. He played a guilty to assault and battery and was sentenced to five years in prison. A mandatory psychiatric report concluded that the likelihood of Bell reoffending was very high. In one counseling session he told the psychiatrist, I feel uncontrollable urges to attack females and want help before I really heard someone. Regardless, two years into his sentence, he was released. A couple of years later, in 1979, a 10-year-old girl began receiving obscene phone calls in which the caller detailed various sex acts he wanted the two to perform
同样，她进行了反抗，贝尔被捕。他承认犯有袭击和殴打罪，被判处五年监禁。一份强制性的精神病报告得出结论，贝尔再次犯罪的可能性非常高。在一次咨询中，他告诉精神科医生：“我有无法控制的攻击女性的冲动，想在真正伤害某人之前寻求帮助。”尽管如此，他在服刑两年后就被释放了。几年后的1979年，一名10岁女孩开始接到淫秽电话，打电话的人详细描述了他想两人一起进行的各种性行为。
together. He seemed to know where the girl lived and threatened to stop by her house. The girl's mother eventually recorded the calls, and they were traced back to Belle. Again he pleaded guilty, but was only given a two-year suspended sentence. By the time of the Smith Helmick attacks, Larry Jean Bell had spent the past three years living with his parents on Scholl Island in Lake Murray. He rarely saw his 12-year-old child, and made ends meet by doing casual electrical jobs for various contractors. When Ellis and Sharon Shepard asked the bell if he wanted to house it while they travelled for six weeks, he jumped at the chance.
他似乎知道女孩住在哪里，并威胁要到她家去。女孩的母亲最终录下了这些电话，并追踪到了贝尔。他再次认罪，但只被判处两年缓刑。在史密斯和赫尔米克袭击案发生时，拉里·吉恩·贝尔已经在默里湖的肖尔岛与父母同住了三年。他很少见到他12岁的孩子，靠为各种承包商做零工来维持生计。当埃利斯和莎伦·谢泼德问贝尔是否愿意在他们旅行六周期间看家时，他欣然接受了。
But when Bell picked the couple up from the airport upon their return, they were a little taken aback. In the short amount of time they'd been away, Bell had lost about 10 pounds, had stopped shaving and looked generally exhausted and unkempt. He seemed a bit out of it. All he wanted to talk about was the kidnapping and murder of Sherry Smith. Sherrin had asked him to save any news about the case so she could catch up on the events when she got home.
但当贝尔在他们回来时从机场接这对夫妇时，他们有点吃惊。在他们离开的短时间内，贝尔瘦了大约10磅，停止了刮胡子，看起来非常疲惫和不修边幅。他看起来有点心不在焉。他只想谈论沙里·史密斯的绑架和谋杀案。莎伦曾要求他保存有关该案的任何新闻，以便她在回家后能赶上事件的进展。
But to her surprise, Belle had gone above and beyond, clipping newspaper articles from every newspaper in the area. When the shepherds saw the revised sketch of the suspect, they paused. It looked remarkably similar to Larry Jean Bell. They considered for a moment whether he could have something to do with the crimes, but quickly shook this thought off. Although Bell could be of its strange and spaced out at times, they believed that there was no way he was capable of anything so heinous.
但令她惊讶的是，贝尔做得非常出色，剪下了该地区每一份报纸上的新闻文章。当谢泼德夫妇看到修改后的嫌疑人素描时，他们停顿了一下。它看起来与拉里·吉恩·贝尔惊人地相似。他们考虑了一会儿他是否可能与这些罪行有关，但很快打消了这个念头。虽然贝尔有时会显得奇怪和恍惚，但他们认为他不可能做出如此令人发指的事情。
Bell was generally a quiet reserved person who'd never given them or anyone else any cause for concern. Neighbors knew him to be kind and gentle, the type of guy you could count on for help and who made a great fishing buddy. As one former co-worker later told the Charlotte observer. Bell was always smiling and laughing. He was the most likable person you ever knew. Ellis Sheppard tried to dismiss the idea that Bell could be involved in the recent murders, but the similarities he bore with the suspects get nagged at him. Late one night, Ellis felt compelled to check on his gun. He kept
贝尔通常是一个安静、内向的人，从未给他们或其他人带来任何担忧。邻居们知道他善良、温柔，是那种你可以指望寻求帮助的人，也是一个很棒的钓鱼伙伴。正如一位前同事后来告诉《夏洛特观察家报》的那样：“贝尔总是面带微笑，笑声不断。他是我认识的最讨人喜欢的人。”埃利斯·谢泼德试图打消贝尔可能参与最近谋杀案的想法，但他与嫌疑人的相似之处一直困扰着他。一天深夜，埃利斯感到有必要检查一下他的枪。他保留着
a loaded pistol at home and had told Belle about it in case he needed it for protection while they were gone. But the gun wasn't there. Ellis called Belle and asked about it. Belle explained that he'd kept the pistol under the mattress of the guest bed he'd been sleeping in. Larry went into the guest room and lifted the mattress. There, lay a copy of Hossler magazine. On the cover was a blonde woman dressed in bondage ear and placed in a crucifix position. Beside the magazine was Ellis's gun. He picked it up. It had been recently fired. On the morning of Wednesday June 26, 1985, Larry Jean Bell made his way to the Shepherd's House to begin a day of electrical work.
家里有一把上膛的手枪，他曾告诉贝尔这件事，以防他们离开时需要防身。但枪不在那里。埃利斯给贝尔打电话询问此事。贝尔解释说，他把手枪放在了他睡的客房床垫下。拉里走进客房，掀起床垫。那里躺着一本《好色客》杂志。封面上是一个穿着束缚装备、摆出十字架姿势的金发女郎。杂志旁边就是埃利斯的枪。他捡起枪。枪最近被开过火。1985年6月26日星期三早上，拉里·吉恩·贝尔前往牧羊人之家开始一天的电气工作。
He was driving a grey Buick Riviera, a car that didn't match the vehicle used in either abduction. As he approached an intersection, a police car cut him off and an officer placed him under a rest without incident. Inside his vehicle, officers found a double-edged knife on the passenger seat. Bell appeared to be caught off guard, but not completely surprised, asking simply, can I call my mama? Bell was taken into custody while search warrants were executed at the Shepherd's
他开着一辆灰色的别克里维拉，这辆车与两起绑架案中使用的车辆都不符。当他接近一个十字路口时，一辆警车截住了他，一名警官在没有发生冲突的情况下将他逮捕。在车内，警官在副驾驶座位上发现了一把双刃刀。贝尔看起来措手不及，但并不完全惊讶，只是简单地问：“我能给我妈妈打个电话吗？”贝尔被拘留，同时搜查令在牧羊人之家执行。
home. The guest room that Bell had been staying in was meticulously clean. It appeared to have been recently dusted and evacuoned and the bed linen was freshly washed. But when investigators removed the sheets, a special laser machine determined that the mattress top up was stained
贝尔一直住的客房非常干净。看起来像是刚打扫过、吸过尘，床单也是刚洗过的。但当调查人员移开床单时，一台特殊的激光机确定床垫顶部沾有尿液、精液和血液的混合物。血液是A型，与雪莉·史密斯的血型相同。还发现了红色纤维。这些纤维与在雪莉尸体上发现的红色纤维进行了比对，确定是匹配的。法医调查人员花了12个小时仔细检查了该房产。在浴室里，他们发现了六根金发，经证实与雪莉的头发相符。
with a mix of urine, semen, and blood. The blood was type A, the same type as sherry smiths. Red fibers were also found. These were compared to red fibers found on sherry's body and determined to be a match. Forensic investigators spent 12 hours painstakingly examining the property. In the bathroom, they found six blonde hairs confirmed to be a match to sharies.
（注：原文索引55内容与54部分重叠，此处按要求翻译）法医调查人员花了12个小时仔细检查了该房产。在浴室里，他们发现了六根金发，经证实与雪莉的头发相符。
A search warrant was also executed at the lakefront home of Bell's parents, who were upstanding well-regarded citizens in their local community. Unsurprisingly to investigators, Bell's bedroom was meticulously organized. He had a large pornography collection with a focus on BDSM. A search of his dresser drawers revealed a bag of women's underwear, with one pair of silk briefs similar to those that Debra May Helmick had been dressed in. Also found was a sheet of postage stamps featuring commemorative duck decoys. The same as the stamp used to mail Shari Smith's last will and testament.
搜查令也在贝尔父母位于湖畔的家中执行，他们是当地社区受人尊敬的正直公民。调查人员并不感到意外，贝尔的卧室整理得井井有条。他有大量的色情收藏，重点是BDSM。搜查他的梳妆台抽屉发现了一袋女性内衣，其中一条丝绸内裤与黛布拉·梅·赫尔米克所穿的相似。还发现了一张印有纪念鸭子诱饵的邮票。这与寄送雪莉·史密斯遗嘱时使用的邮票相同。
Meanwhile, police combed through the surveillance photos taken from Sherry's grave. In one, they saw a car parked on the roadside right near the grave. The driver never got out of the car. As search of the license plate revealed, the car was registered to none other than Larry Jean Bell. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. The circumstantial evidence against Bell was stacking up, but to secure a conviction, investigators
与此同时，警方仔细梳理了从雪莉墓地拍摄的监控照片。在其中一张照片中，他们看到一辆车停在墓地附近的路边。司机从未下车。对车牌的搜索显示，这辆车登记在拉里·吉恩·贝尔名下。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供优质内容。针对贝尔的间接证据正在堆积，但为了确保定罪，调查人员
were hoping for one thing in particular, a confession. But upon questioning, Bell repeatedly denied any involvement in the murders of Shari Smith or Debra May Helmick. He told interviewing detectives, This Larry Jean Bell didn't do it. It's the bad Larry Jean Bell. I know for a fact that Larry Jean Bell did not do that to these poor women. I'm not lying to you. I'll do everything I can to help you, but I can't confess for someone else. When pressed further, Bell said. All I know is that the Larry Jean Bell sitting here
特别希望得到一样东西：供词。但在审讯中，贝尔一再否认参与了雪莉·史密斯或黛布拉·梅·赫尔米克的谋杀案。他告诉审讯侦探：“这个拉里·吉恩·贝尔没做这件事。是那个坏的拉里·吉恩·贝尔做的。我确信拉里·吉恩·贝尔没有对这些可怜的女人做那种事。我没有对你们撒谎。我会尽我所能帮助你们，但我不能为别人认罪。”当被进一步追问时，贝尔说：“我只知道坐在这里的拉里·吉恩·贝尔
couldn't have done such a thing. But there's a bad Larry Jean Bell that could have. He then made an odd request. Could he meet with Shari's family? Hilda and Dawn courageously agreed and were taken into the interrogation room. Bell began to mumble that the person sitting before them could not be capable of such quote, ungodly things.
不可能做出那种事。但有一个坏的拉里·吉恩·贝尔可能会做。他随后提出了一个奇怪的要求。他能见见雪莉的家人吗？希尔达和道恩勇敢地同意了，并被带进了审讯室。贝尔开始嘟囔说，坐在他们面前的人不可能做出那种“不敬神”的事情。
While he admitted to feeling some form of guilt, he made no confession. Bell told Hilda, If I'm directly responsible for this crime, I do apologize if I've brought tragedy into your lives and tragedy to myself. I don't know what to say to you. I just can't believe I've done those terrible things. The mother and daughter made it very clear to Bell that they knew he was the man responsible for killing Shari. His denial filled dawn with disgust.
虽然他承认感到某种形式的内疚，但他没有认罪。贝尔告诉希尔达：“如果我直接对这起罪行负责，如果我给你们的生活带来了悲剧，也给自己带来了悲剧，我确实道歉。我不知道该对你们说什么。我只是不敢相信我做了那些可怕的事情。”母女俩非常明确地告诉贝尔，她们知道他就是杀害雪莉的凶手。他的否认让道恩感到厌恶。
At the very least she hoped he'd be man enough to own up to his actions and apologize. Regardless, Hilda told him, I don't hate you. There is not enough room in my heart for more pain." After interviewing friends and family members, investigators could find no evidence to indicate that Larry Jean Bell and Sherry Smith were known to one another prior to May 31, 1985. It appeared that Sherry had simply been in the wrong place at the wrong time. On the afternoon of Shari's disappearance, Bell had been in downtown Lexington, dropping his mother at a doctor's appointment. He had likely caught sight of Shari as she got into her car after her France pool party and made the decision to follow her home from
至少她希望他能有男子气概，承认自己的行为并道歉。无论如何，希尔达告诉他：“我不恨你。我的心里没有空间容纳更多的痛苦了。”在采访了朋友和家人后，调查人员找不到任何证据表明拉里·吉恩·贝尔和雪莉·史密斯在1985年5月31日之前认识。雪莉似乎只是在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点。在雪莉失踪的当天下午，贝尔一直在列克星敦市中心，送他母亲去看医生。他很可能在雪莉参加完法国泳池派对后上车时看到了她，并决定从那里跟踪她回家。
there. Although Bell had probably been fantasizing about pulling off such a crime for a while, the attack was somewhat opportunistic. When Sharia arrived at her house and got out of her car to check the mail, Bell likely approached her, brandishing a gun and demanded she get into his car. Bell likely approached her, brandishing a gun, and demanded she get into his car. Back at the Shepitz house, he answered a call from a friend who worked as a waitress at a local restaurant. Bell's parents had just arrived for dinner, and she invited Bell to come join them. Bell said he'd rather stay in and watch the college world series baseball game instead. At this point, investigators believed Shari was tied to the bed, terrified. A night of sexual assault likely preceded Shari's eventual murder at 4.58am, the time that
虽然贝尔可能已经幻想实施这样的犯罪有一段时间了，但这次袭击在某种程度上是机会主义的。当雪莉到达她家并下车检查邮件时，贝尔很可能走近她，挥舞着枪，要求她上他的车。回到牧羊人之家，他接到了一个在当地餐馆当服务员的朋友的电话。贝尔的父母刚到那里吃晚饭，她邀请贝尔加入他们。贝尔说他宁愿待在家里看大学棒球世界大赛。此时，调查人员认为雪莉被绑在床上，惊恐万分。一夜的性侵犯很可能发生在雪莉最终被谋杀之前，时间是凌晨4点58分，那是
Belle told the Smith family their souls became one. During the search of Bell's bedroom, officers found a business card for a top-soil company located on Old Percival Road, directly across from the trailer park where the homeic family lived. The company belonged to Bell's sister, Diane. Diane and her husband occasionally hired Belle to do some work for their business. Investigators theorized that Belle had caught sight of 9-year-old Debra May Helmick while working for his sister and had targeted her because of her blonde hair, and the fact should be easy to control.
贝尔告诉史密斯一家他们灵魂合二为一的时间。在搜查贝尔的卧室时，警官发现了一张位于老珀西瓦尔路上的表土公司的名片，就在赫尔米克一家居住的拖车公园对面。该公司属于贝尔的妹妹黛安。黛安和她的丈夫偶尔会雇佣贝尔为他们的生意做些工作。调查人员推测，贝尔在为他妹妹工作时看到了9岁的黛布拉·梅·赫尔米克，并因为她金色的头发以及她容易控制的事实而盯上了她。
From the outset of the investigation, criminal profilers believed the serial killer would keep trophies of his victims. Despite extensive searches of Bell's home and vehicle, nothing belonging to Shari Smith or Debra Mayholmeck was found. But there was no denying Larry Jean Bell's obsession with the two cases. Not only had he kept the extensive collection of newspaper clippings for Sharon Shepard, a neighbor recalled that Bell had been eager to bring up Sherry's kidnapping the day after it happened.
从调查一开始，犯罪侧写师就认为连环杀手会保留受害者的战利品。尽管对贝尔的家和车辆进行了广泛的搜查，但没有发现属于雪莉·史密斯或黛布拉·梅·赫尔米克的任何东西。但不可否认拉里·吉恩·贝尔对这两个案件的痴迷。他不仅保留了大量关于雪莉·谢泼德的剪报，一位邻居还回忆说，贝尔在雪莉绑架案发生的第二天就急于提起这件事。
He claimed to be a good friend of the Smith family and had made the odd comment, she's dead now. The neighbor hadn't thought anything off at the time, but he did notice one thing. Bell had always sported a full beard. The day after Shari's kidnapping, he was clean-shaven. Questions remained regarding the vehicles used in the abductions. The only car linked to Bell was the great Buick he'd been driving at the time of his arrest. Two days prior to this, a cranberry-colored Buick regal had been found abandoned in a hotel car park.
他声称自己是史密斯一家的好朋友，并发表了奇怪的评论：“她现在死了。”邻居当时没多想，但他确实注意到了一件事。贝尔一直留着浓密的胡子。雪莉绑架案发生的第二天，他刮得干干净净。关于绑架案中使用的车辆仍有疑问。唯一与贝尔有关的汽车是他被捕时驾驶的那辆灰色别克。在此之前两天，一辆蔓越莓色的别克君威在一家酒店停车场被发现被遗弃。
A search revealed it had been reported stolen in April, and the thief had never been apprehended. But there was no evidence inside to link it to Bell. Nor could investigators find the silver-colored General Motors vehicle used in the abduction of Debra May Helmick. However, when Bell was arrested, officers searched his car and found a license plate in the trunk that didn't match those on display. The witness to Debra Mazibduction recalled the kidnapper's license plate beginning with
搜查显示它在四月份被报失窃，窃贼从未被抓获。但车内没有证据将其与贝尔联系起来。调查人员也无法找到在绑架黛布拉·梅·赫尔米克时使用的银色通用汽车。然而，当贝尔被捕时，警官搜查了他的车，在后备箱里发现了一个与展示的车牌不符的车牌。黛布拉·梅绑架案的目击者回忆说，绑架者的车牌以字母D开头。贝尔车内的车牌是DCE 604。
the letter D. The plate inside Bell's vehicle, red, DCE, 604. Number 104 News that an arrest had been made in the Smith-Helmic case was met with mixed reactions. While members of the community breathed the collective sigh of relief that someone had finally been held accountable, those who knew Belle were in disbelief. Neighbors and former colleagues struggled to comprehend that the friendly and likable person they knew could be capable of such crimes. Many were convinced that police had caught the wrong guy, but investigators had no doubts. After sorting out some complex jurisdictional issues, Larry Jean Bell was officially charged
104新闻报道称，史密斯-赫尔米克案的逮捕消息引起了复杂的反应。虽然社区成员集体松了一口气，认为终于有人被追究责任，但那些认识贝尔的人却感到难以置信。邻居和前同事很难理解他们认识的那个友好且讨人喜欢的人竟然能做出这样的罪行。许多人确信警方抓错了人，但调查人员毫无疑问。在理清了一些复杂的管辖权问题后，拉里·吉恩·贝尔被正式指控
with the kidnapping and murder of both Sherry Smith and Debra May Helmick. Both cases would be tried separately. Both carried the possibility of the death penalty. But there was something else that investigators needed to get to the bottom of. While Bell was being transported for one of his court hearings, he turned to one of the accompanying officers. Bell said that he wanted to speak to law enforcement in Charlotte, a city in the neighboring state of North Carolina, saying, I want to tell them some things about a missing girl named Sandy. 26-year-old Sandy Cornette was an insurance adjuster and a part-time model who lived in East Charlotte. On Sunday, November 18, 1984, Sandy had dinner at home with her fiance, who then left
绑架并谋杀了雪莉·史密斯和黛布拉·梅·赫尔米克。两起案件将分别审理。两起案件都可能判处死刑。但调查人员还需要弄清楚另一件事。当贝尔被送往参加其中一次法庭听证会时，他转向其中一名随行警官。贝尔说他想和北卡罗来纳州邻州夏洛特的执法部门谈谈，说：“我想告诉他们一些关于一个叫桑迪的失踪女孩的事情。”26岁的桑迪·科内特是一名保险理算员和兼职模特，住在东夏洛特。1984年11月18日星期日，桑迪在家和未婚夫吃了晚饭，未婚夫随后离开
to spend the night at his own home. When Sandy failed to shower but worked the next day with no explanation, police went to her house to conduct a welfare check. The house was empty, but the television was on. The contents of Sandy's purse had been dumped under her bed, but nothing was missing besides a single ATM card. And there was no sign of a break-in or a struggle. Based on clothes missing from her cupboard, it was deduced that Sandy had been wearing a navy blue velua jogging suit at the time of her disappearance. Police considered whether she could have been attacked upon returning home from a run,
去他自己的家过夜。当桑迪第二天没有去上班且没有解释时，警方去了她家进行福利检查。房子是空的，但电视开着。桑迪钱包里的东西被倒在床下，但除了一张ATM卡外，什么都没少。没有闯入或挣扎的迹象。根据她橱柜里丢失的衣服，推测桑迪在失踪时穿着一套海军蓝丝绒慢跑服。警方考虑她是否在跑步回家时遭到袭击，
but those who knew Sandy said she often wore her running clothes when lounging around the house. However, they also said she was not the type to ever open the door to a stranger. This raised the possibility Had Sandy been abducted by someone she knew. For days, investigators searched the surrounding areas, but no sign of Sandy Cornette was found. A trace was put on Sandy's missing ATM card, providing what appeared to be a breakthrough, when it was revealed that the card had been used several times at a bank in Charlotte
但认识桑迪的人说，她在家里休息时经常穿跑步服。然而，他们也说她不是那种会给陌生人开门的人。这提出了一个可能性：桑迪是被她认识的人绑架的吗？几天来，调查人员搜查了周边地区，但没有发现桑迪·科内特的踪迹。警方对桑迪丢失的ATM卡进行了追踪，当发现该卡在夏洛特的一家银行被多次使用时，似乎取得了突破。
by a man and woman. These suspects weren't identified, and Sandy's case eventually went cold. That all changed as Larry Jean Bell unpromptedly began telling the accompanying officer. On Monday, God is going to reveal to me where Sandy Cornette's body is. He said her hands would be folded in prayer position, just like with Shari Smith. An interview was arranged between Belle and authorities in Charlotte, during which he ranted for 12 hours, saying that he was the most gifted man in the world, and that God zapped messages down to him.
由一男一女使用。这些嫌疑人没有被确认身份，桑迪的案件最终成了悬案。当拉里·吉恩·贝尔主动开始告诉随行警官时，一切都变了。他说：“周一，上帝会向我揭示桑迪·科内特的尸体在哪里。”他说她的双手会像雪莉·史密斯那样折叠成祈祷姿势。贝尔和夏洛特的当局安排了一次面谈，期间他喋喋不休了12个小时，说他是世界上最有天赋的人，上帝会把信息传给他。
He claimed everything he knew about Sandy Cornette was revealed to him by God. Investigators did some digging and realized that at the time of Sandy's disappearance, Larry Jean Bell lived just four miles from Sandy's home in Charlotte's Mint Hill District. The two were vaguely known to one another, having met at a party years prior through a former boyfriend of Sandys who worked with Bell at Eastern Airlines. Just a few weeks after Sandy vanished, Bell moved away. The theft element of Sandy's disappearance didn't fit with Bell's ammo, but he was able to give accurate details about the ATM with the drools that had never been released to the public.
他声称他所知道的关于桑迪·科内特的一切都是上帝向他揭示的。调查人员进行了一些挖掘，意识到在桑迪失踪时，拉里·吉恩·贝尔住在夏洛特薄荷山区的桑迪家仅四英里处。两人模糊地认识，几年前通过桑迪的一位前男友在聚会上见过面，该男友曾在东方航空公司与贝尔一起工作。在桑迪失踪几周后，贝尔搬走了。桑迪失踪案中的盗窃因素与贝尔的作案手法不符，但他能够提供关于ATM取款的准确细节，这些细节从未向公众披露过。
Bell quickly rose to the position of Prime Suspect, but investigators failed to find any concrete evidence linking him to the crime. But Sandy Cornette wasn't the only one. During his 12-hour interview, Bell hinted at having knowledge about two other cases involving young women. Although he didn't mention the individuals by name, investigators looked into other unsolved cases from around Charlotte at the time Bell lived there and found two that matched his ammo. 21-year-old Denise Portch lived with her husband at an apartment complex in Southwest Charlotte,
贝尔迅速上升为主要嫌疑人，但调查人员未能找到将他与该罪行联系起来的具体证据。但桑迪·科内特并不是唯一一个。在他12小时的面谈中，贝尔暗示他了解另外两起涉及年轻女性的案件。虽然他没有提到这些人的名字，但调查人员调查了贝尔居住在夏洛特时发生的其他未解案件，并发现了两起符合他作案手法的案件。21岁的丹妮丝·波奇和她的丈夫住在夏洛特西南部的一个公寓大楼里，
where she also worked as the residential manager. At 8pm on Monday, July 21, 1975, her husband returned home from a day out to find a note from Denise from earlier, saying she was going to show an apartment to a prospective tenant. The television and air conditioner were still on. Denise's purse was inside, and her car was still parked outside. But there was no sign of Denise herself, nor was there any sign of a struggle. The years went by without a single trace of Denise surfacing, or anyone being held accountable for her disappearance. At the time, Larry Jean Bell lived just 300 yards
她也在那里担任住宅经理。1975年7月21日星期一晚上8点，她的丈夫从外面回来，发现丹妮丝早些时候留下的一张纸条，说她要带一位潜在租户看公寓。电视和空调还开着。丹妮丝的钱包在里面，她的车还停在外面。但没有丹妮丝本人的踪迹，也没有挣扎的迹象。岁月流逝，丹妮丝没有留下任何痕迹，也没有人因她的失踪而被追究责任。当时，拉里·吉恩·贝尔住在仅300码
away. On Thursday, December 18, 1980, the body of 17-year-old Beth Marie Hagen was found dumped in the woods near Mint Hill. She had been strangled with an electrical cord. Bell lived just one mile away. Not only did this put him within the vicinity of both unsolved crimes, but like Shari Smith and Debra May Helmick, Denise Pch and Beth Hagen were blondes who fit Bell's preferred victim type. In September 1985, acting on a tip-off, police searched a sand pit at the topsoil company on Old Percival Road owned by Larry Jean Bell's sister and brother-in-law. Suspissions were raised that the bodies of Sandy Cornette or Denise Porch could be found there. The search turned up nothing. Not a single piece of evidence was found
远的地方。1980年12月18日星期四，17岁的贝丝·玛丽·哈根的尸体在薄荷山附近的树林里被发现。她被电线勒死。贝尔住在仅一英里远的地方。这不仅使他处于两起未解罪行的附近，而且像雪莉·史密斯和黛布拉·梅·赫尔米克一样，丹妮丝·波奇和贝丝·哈根都是符合贝尔偏好受害者类型的金发女郎。1985年9月，根据线报，警方搜查了拉里·吉恩·贝尔的妹妹和妹夫拥有的老珀西瓦尔路上的表土公司的一个沙坑。人们怀疑桑迪·科内特或丹妮丝·波奇的尸体可能在那里。搜查一无所获。没有发现任何证据
linking Bell to either of the three cold cases. By the time Bell's trial for the kidnapping and murder of Sherry Smith commenced in February 1986, public interest in the case hadn't dissipated. Curious members of the public lined up outside the courthouse of vying for a seat inside, with two women even breaking into a fight. Bell arrived with a shaved head and a homemade badge pinned to his shirt that read, I am the victim, I am innocent. Bell's defense lawyer didn't deny that his client was responsible for Sherry's kidnapping, but said there was no proof that he was guilty of murder. Either way, the lawyer argued that Belle should be found not guilty due to mental illness. According to the lawyer, the multiple calls that Belle had made to the Smith family were
将贝尔与这三起悬案中的任何一起联系起来。当贝尔因绑架和谋杀雪莉·史密斯的审判于1986年2月开始时，公众对该案的兴趣并没有消退。好奇的公众在法院外排队争抢里面的座位，两名妇女甚至打了起来。贝尔剃了光头，衬衫上别着一个自制的徽章，上面写着：“我是受害者，我是无辜的。”贝尔的辩护律师没有否认他的客户应对雪莉的绑架负责，但表示没有证据证明他犯有谋杀罪。无论如何，律师辩称，由于精神疾病，贝尔应被判无罪。据律师称，贝尔给史密斯一家打的多个电话是
proof that he was mentally unstable, delirious, and out of touch with reality. He asked the jury, how many rational people who had abducted someone and who may have caused a death would call the family collect so the call could be traced. The prosecution argued that anyone out of touch with reality would be incapable of tormenting Sherry's family the way that Bell did. They believed that Bell's mentally unstable behavior was all an act, and that securing a conviction of not guilty on account of mental illness would be a victory for Bell. As one psychologist who had spent significant time with Bell testified, he wasn't mentally ill.
他精神不稳定、神志不清、与现实脱节的证据。他问陪审团：“有多少绑架了某人并可能导致死亡的理性人会给家人打对方付费电话，以便追踪到电话？”检方辩称，任何与现实脱节的人都不可能像贝尔那样折磨雪莉的家人。他们认为贝尔精神不稳定的行为全是演戏，以精神疾病为由获得无罪判决对贝尔来说将是一场胜利。正如一位与贝尔相处了很长时间的心理学家作证的那样，他并没有精神疾病。
He simply had no conscience and derived sexual pleasure from the pain of others. The prosecution lawyer asked the jury, the question is simple, whether or not Lary Jean Bell could follow the law, or whether or not Lary Jean Bell would follow the law. From the outset of the trial, Bell's conduct in court was unpredictable and disruptive. He often interrupted proceedings by calling out nonsensical comments. When one psychiatrist testified that he was a sadistic sexual deviant, even though it was in his defense, Bell turned to the press rose and said, if you all believe that, Mona Lisa is a man. In a risky move for the defense, Bell also took the stand.
他只是没有良心，并从他人的痛苦中获得性快感。检方律师问陪审团：“问题很简单，拉里·吉恩·贝尔是否能遵守法律，或者拉里·吉恩·贝尔是否会遵守法律。”从审判一开始，贝尔在法庭上的行为就不可预测且具有破坏性。他经常通过喊出毫无意义的评论来打断诉讼程序。当一位精神科医生作证说他是一个虐待狂性变态者时，尽管这是为了他的辩护，贝尔还是转向媒体席说：“如果你们都相信这一点，那蒙娜丽莎就是个男人。”在辩方的一次冒险举动中，贝尔也出庭作证。
He wouldn't sit down, saying, there are no chairs at the gates of hell. He refused to answer even basic questions such as his age, instead repeatedly saying, silence is golden. At one point he told the press, I'm so confused, ain't we haven't fun. Later he turned to the jury and said, Food for thought. Gifted, dumb, or a fruitcake. You pick one. But if the defense hoped that putting Bell on the stand would prove to the jury how irrational he was, their plan failed. After closing arguments, it took the jury less than an hour to deliver their verdict. Guilty on both counts. Outside court, a reporter asked Belle how he felt about the verdict.
他不肯坐下，说：“地狱之门没有椅子。”他拒绝回答即使是年龄这样的基本问题，而是反复说：“沉默是金。”有一次他告诉媒体：“我很困惑，我们玩得不开心吗？”后来他转向陪审团说：“供思考。天才、傻瓜还是疯子。你们选一个。”但如果辩方希望贝尔出庭能向陪审团证明他有多不理性，他们的计划失败了。结案陈词后，陪审团用了不到一个小时就做出了裁决。两项罪名均成立。法庭外，一名记者问贝尔对判决有何感想。
He responded, Silence is golden, my friend. Belle's sentencing took place two days later. At one point, he turned to Dawn Smith in court and asked, ''Dawn, will you marry me my singing angel? Look into my eyes, my holy angel.'' He told the jury, ''From the top of my head to the tips of my feet,
他回答说：“沉默是金，我的朋友。”贝尔的判决两天后进行。有一次，他在法庭上转向道恩·史密斯并问道：“道恩，你愿意嫁给我吗，我的歌唱天使？看着我的眼睛，我的圣洁天使。”他告诉陪审团：“从我的头顶到我的脚尖，
I'm lasting for Dawn Elizabeth Smith. I'd like to take her hand in holy matrimony. That's the only thing I'm guilty of. The prosecution had implored the jury to impose the death penalty, saying, if this isn't the type of case in which the state should seek the death penalty and expect the death penalty, then there is none. The jury agreed. For the kidnapping and murder of Shari Smith, Larry Jean Bell was sentenced to death. It was over a year before the family of Debra May Helmick finally got their day in court,
我都在渴望道恩·伊丽莎白·史密斯。我想在神圣的婚姻中牵她的手。这是我唯一有罪的事情。”检方恳求陪审团判处死刑，称：“如果这不是州政府应该寻求死刑并期望死刑的案件类型，那么就没有这种案件了。”陪审团同意了。因绑架和谋杀雪莉·史密斯，拉里·吉恩·贝尔被判处死刑。一年多后，黛布拉·梅·赫尔米克的家人终于等到了他们的法庭日，
and it couldn't come soon enough. Young Woody Helmick continued to struggle in the wake of his sister's murder. He was plagued by nightmares caused by witnessing the kidnapping, and it was constantly terrified that the bad man would come back to get him. He refused to go anywhere alone. The Helmix had no doubt that police had caught the right person. As reported by the Columbia record, when Woody saw Larry Jean Bell in court during the Smith trial, he turned to his mother and said, he's the man that took Debbie.
而且这一天来得太晚了。年轻的伍迪·赫尔米克在姐姐被谋杀后继续挣扎。他被目睹绑架造成的噩梦所困扰，并且一直害怕坏人会回来抓他。他拒绝独自去任何地方。赫尔米克一家毫不怀疑警方抓住了正确的人。据《哥伦比亚记录报》报道，当伍迪在史密斯案审判期间在法庭上看到拉里·吉恩·贝尔时，他转向他的母亲说：“他就是带走黛比的那个人。”
The Helmix prepared themselves for Bell's court rheumatics after he once again pleaded not guilty to Debra May's kidnapping and murder, but they needn't bother. In contrast to his previous trial, Bell remained silent throughout the proceedings and showed no emotion. The defense didn't call any witnesses, introduce any new evidence, or put Bell on the stand. Again, it took the jury just one hour to find Larry Jean Bell guilty on both counts, and again, he was sentenced to death. As Bell sat on death row appealing his sentences, police received a tip off from a young man who claimed his conscience had been eating away at him for years.
赫尔米克一家在贝尔再次对黛布拉·梅的绑架和谋杀案表示不认罪后，准备迎接贝尔的法庭闹剧，但他们不必担心。与之前的审判相比，贝尔在整个诉讼过程中保持沉默，没有表现出任何情绪。辩方没有传唤任何证人，没有引入任何新证据，也没有让贝尔出庭。同样，陪审团仅用了一个小时就认定拉里·吉恩·贝尔两项罪名成立，他再次被判处死刑。当贝尔在死囚牢房对他的判决提出上诉时，警方收到了一名年轻人的线报，他声称自己的良心多年来一直折磨着他。
According to this informant, in 1984 at the age of 15, he and a friend were hitchhiking along the Interstate 85 Highway in Cherokee County, Georgia. Larry Jean Bell picked them up and took them to a location four miles off the highway. Bell allegedly led them to an abandoned well where he showed the teenagers two dead bodies. According to the informant, Bell warned, According to the informant, Bell warned, if you don't do what I say, that's what will happen to you. Investigators weren't sure what to make of the claim, but the timeline matched with Sandy Cornette's disappearance,
据这位线人称，1984年他15岁时，他和朋友在佐治亚州切罗基县的85号州际公路上搭便车。拉里·吉恩·贝尔接了他们，把他们带到了离高速公路四英里远的一个地方。贝尔据称把他们带到了一口废弃的井边，在那里他向青少年展示了两具尸体。据线人称，贝尔警告说：“如果你不按我说的做，这就是你的下场。”调查人员不确定该如何看待这一说法，但时间线与桑迪·科内特的失踪相吻合，
so they weren't taking any chances. If Bell was indeed responsible for Sandy's death, they needed to work fast to secure a conviction before his execution. Despite eight years passing since this alleged incident, the young man was able to retrace his steps through the rural dirt roads and thick woods of Cherokee County. He couldn't recall the exact location of the well, but remembered that it was near an old ranch-style farmhouse and a wooden bridge. Leading a search party of 30 officers, dozens of abandoned wells were located, and through a process of elimination, investigators honed in on one. Water was pumped from the well, and a high-tech camera was used to search within, but no human remains were found.
所以他们不敢冒险。如果贝尔确实对桑迪的死负责，他们需要在执行死刑前迅速采取行动以确保定罪。尽管距离这起所谓的事件已经过去了八年，但这位年轻人还是能够沿着切罗基县的乡村土路和茂密的树林重走他的足迹。他不记得井的确切位置，但记得它靠近一个旧牧场风格的农舍和一座木桥。带领一支由30名警官组成的搜查队，定位了数十口废弃的井，通过排除法，调查人员锁定了一口。水从井中抽出，并使用高科技摄像机在内部进行搜索，但没有发现人类遗骸。
Throughout his time on Death Row, Bell's questionable behaviour continued. One psychiatrist once found him naked and washing himself with water from the toilet bowl. He claimed to be the second to Jesus Christ and that he bathed in his own urine because it was holy water. He told another psychiatrist that there was a bird in his cell who had been sent to him by God. According to Bell, he could memorize even the most complex medical textbook in one night. As the years went on, concerns were raised that Bell would be found incompetent for execution due to mental illness.
在死囚牢房期间，贝尔令人质疑的行为仍在继续。一位精神科医生曾发现他赤身裸体，用马桶里的水洗澡。他声称自己是耶稣基督的第二位，他用自己的尿液洗澡，因为那是圣水。他告诉另一位精神科医生，他的牢房里有一只鸟，是上帝派给他的。据贝尔说，他可以在一晚内背诵即使是最复杂的医学教科书。随着岁月的流逝，人们担心贝尔会因精神疾病而被认定不适合执行死刑。
Once he'd exhausted all appeals, a competency hearing was held to determine whether he was mentally fit. The judge concluded that Bell was able to control his mental illness and exaggerate his problems when it benefited him, and therefore was competent for execution. Sheriff James Matt's told reporters for News 19. He ruined the families of two beautiful young ladies. He ruined the community of Lexington and greater Columbia. Larry Jean Bell deserves to die, and he should have died a long time ago.
一旦他用尽了所有上诉，就举行了一次能力听证会，以确定他是否精神健全。法官得出结论，贝尔能够控制自己的精神疾病，并在对他有利时夸大自己的问题，因此有能力执行死刑。詹姆斯·马茨警长告诉新闻19台的记者：“他毁了两位美丽年轻女士的家庭。他毁了列克星敦和大哥伦比亚社区。拉里·吉恩·贝尔罪有应得，他早就该死了。”
Bell was given the option of lethal injection or electric chair. He chose the electric chair, reasoning that there were similarities between the wood of the chair and the wood of the crucifix. The execution was scheduled for Friday, October 4, 1996, just over 11 years after his arrest for the murders. Sherry Smith's family chose not to attend, but several of Sherry's friends gathered outside the prison gates holding candles in her memory. Debra May Helmick's mother told News 19 reporters that she felt she owed it to her daughter to be there.
贝尔被给予了注射死刑或电椅的选择。他选择了电椅，理由是椅子上的木头和十字架的木头之间有相似之处。执行日期定于1996年10月4日星期五，距离他因谋杀被捕仅11年多。雪莉·史密斯的家人选择不参加，但雪莉的几位朋友聚集在监狱大门外，手持蜡烛纪念她。黛布拉·梅·赫尔米克的母亲告诉新闻19台的记者，她觉得她欠女儿的，必须在那里。
While she genuinely believed that Larry Jean Bell was mentally ill, she also believed he knew right from wrong and wanted to see him punished for the pain he'd caused her family. Bell gave no last words. If he knew anything about the crimes against Sandy Cornette, Denise Porch or Beth Hagen, he took that knowledge to the grave. For the Helmic family, life was never the same after the day that Deborah May was kidnapped. Her sister Becky, who on the day of the abduction had chosen to drive to work with her mother instead of staying behind to play with her siblings, continued to carry guilt for not being there for Deborah May.
虽然她真诚地相信拉里·吉恩·贝尔患有精神疾病，但她也相信他知道是非对错，并希望看到他为给她的家庭造成的痛苦而受到惩罚。贝尔没有留下遗言。如果他知道任何关于针对桑迪·科内特、丹妮丝·波奇或贝丝·哈根的罪行，他把这些知识带进了坟墓。对于赫尔米克一家来说，黛布拉·梅被绑架的那天之后，生活再也不一样了。她的妹妹贝基，在绑架那天选择和母亲一起开车去上班，而不是留下来和兄弟姐妹玩，因为没有在黛布拉·梅身边而继续背负着内疚。
In the lead-up to Belle's execution, Becky wrote a statement about the impact of Bell's crimes, saying that Debra May was a sweet innocent girl who had never been beyond her childhood years. Becky explained, she had so many hopes, plans and dreams for the future. They just all shattered right in front of my five-year-old eyes. The girl's father, Sherwood Helmick, began drinking heavily to escape his overwhelming grief. He'd spent hours just sitting and staring at photos of Deborah May. Shortly after he's dored as murder, Sherwood lost his job all together. He had a nervous breakdown and was hospitalized
在贝尔执行死刑前夕，贝基写了一份关于贝尔罪行影响的声明，称黛布拉·梅是一个甜美天真的女孩，从未走出童年。贝基解释说：“她对未来有太多的希望、计划和梦想。它们就在我五岁大的眼睛前破碎了。”女孩的父亲舍伍德·赫尔米克开始酗酒以逃避他压倒性的悲伤。他花几个小时只是坐着盯着黛布拉·梅的照片。在谋杀案发生后不久，舍伍德完全失去了工作。他精神崩溃并住院治疗，
where he received a treatment to overcome his alcohol abuse. His wife worked part-time in a struggle to keep up with the bills and to keep food on the table, but it wasn't enough and the hall mix eventually lost their home. But the but it wasn't enough, and the hallmicks eventually lost their home. But the surrounding community wasn't going to let them go down without a fight. Residents of Lexington and Richland counties rallied together to raise money to help the hallmicks
在那里他接受了克服酗酒的治疗。他的妻子兼职工作，努力支付账单并维持生计，但这还不够，赫尔米克一家最终失去了他们的家。但周围的社区不会让他们在没有战斗的情况下倒下。列克星敦和里奇兰县的居民团结起来筹集资金帮助赫尔米克一家
get back on their feet. A chairperson for the fundraiser committee told the Columbia record, A chairperson for the fundraiser committee told the Columbia record, Debra May Helmick is not the only victim here. Her family still suffers every day. They shouldn't have to worry about whether they have a roof over their heads too. Conditions improved for the Helmicks, but sure wouldn't Debra's marriage didn't survive, and they divorced in a lead-up to Bell's execution. Debra May's mother found comfort in her daughter's favorite doll named Scotty, whom she began sleeping with in the wake of the crime. She told a reporter for the state, it's not like having her with me, but it's the next best thing.
重新站起来。筹款委员会的一位主席告诉《哥伦比亚记录报》：“黛布拉·梅·赫尔米克不是这里唯一的受害者。她的家人仍然每天都在受苦。他们不应该还要担心是否有一个屋顶遮头。”赫尔米克一家的条件有所改善，但舍伍德和黛布拉的婚姻没有维持下去，他们在贝尔执行死刑前离婚了。黛布拉·梅的母亲从女儿最喜欢的名叫斯科蒂的玩偶中找到了安慰，她在犯罪发生后开始抱着它睡觉。她告诉《州报》的一名记者：“这不像有她在身边，但这是次好的选择。”
In Sherry Smith's last will and testament, Sherry had assured her family, some good will come from this. The Smith's clung to this sentiment. For them, that final letter provided more closure than any legal outcomes. Sherry's father Bob continued to serve as chaplain for the Sheriff's Department. At one point, he accompanied officers when they had the unfortunate task of notifying another couple that their daughter had been killed. When the agonized father of the victim realized who Bob was, he threw his arms around him. Bob tearfully told a reporter for the prison fellowship that the two had an immediate bond,
在雪莉·史密斯的遗嘱中，雪莉向她的家人保证：“一些好事会从中产生。”史密斯一家紧紧抓住这种情感。对他们来说，那封最后的信提供了比任何法律结果更多的了结。雪莉的父亲鲍勃继续担任警长部门的牧师。有一次，当他们执行不幸的任务，通知另一对夫妇他们的女儿被杀时，他陪同警官前往。当受害者痛苦的父亲意识到鲍勃是谁时，他搂住了他。鲍勃含泪告诉监狱团契的一名记者，两人有一种直接的联系，
saying, God had me there for a reason. In the years following Shari's murder, her sister Dawn went on to win the Miss South Carolina Beauty Contest. She became a public figure, spreading her message about the importance of keeping faith no matter what life throws our way. Later appearing on the True Crime TV show, I witness, Dawn said, In her final moments, Sherry didn't choose fear. She chose faith and courage. Losing Shari made me realize every day
说：“上帝让我去那里是有原因的。”在雪莉被谋杀后的几年里，她的妹妹道恩赢得了南卡罗来纳小姐选美比赛。她成为了一位公众人物，传播关于无论生活给我们带来什么都要保持信仰的重要性的信息。后来出现在真实犯罪电视节目《目击者》中，道恩说：“在最后的时刻，雪莉没有选择恐惧。她选择了信仰和勇气。”失去雪莉让我意识到每一天
that what I have is a gift God's given me. And I have a decision. What am I going to do with it? I am going to choose faith. you you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我所拥有的都是上帝赐予我的礼物。我有一个决定。我要用它做什么？我将选择信仰。你你这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。